[Music]
for dinner tonight you are being treated
to the tasting menu of a lifetime
the periodic table of elements
which elements would you be able to eat
which ones would smell or
taste funny
[Music]
and which elements would ruin the fun by
killing you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you swallowed all the elements
of the periodic table
the periodic table is how we organize
all the known elements those are
substances with only one type of atom
and they cannot be divided into any
simpler substances
out of the 118 elements that make up the
periodic table some have similar
properties
some behave in similar ways
and some don't even exist naturally
twenty of them need to be created in
laboratories because of how unstable
they are
so if you're feeling adventurous it's
time to add some chemistry to your diet
but you could be risking a lot more than
an upset stomach
your tasting menu would begin with the
elements that are the basic building
blocks of your body
as the waiter would explain the chef has
prepared these six elements in
proportion to you
so enjoy your dish of 65
oxygen
18.5 hydrogen
3.2 percent nitrogen
one and a half percent calcium and one
percent phosphorus
for your next dish the waiter would
bring you a small assortment of elements
that your body relies on to function
please enjoy your six bite-sized
portions of sodium potassium
magnesium selenium iron and copper
lucky for you these are all completely
safe to eat
unless you eat too much
especially copper you'd notice that the
flavor has notes of acidity bitterness
and saltiness
maybe you'd like it enough that you'd
request some more lisa well that would
be a big mistake
now you'd experience a low level amount
of copper toxicity
which could lead to kidney failure brain
damage or
even death if you don't stop eating
right away
um then the waiter would bring over the
next course of several non-reactive
elements with a fancy name
the noble gases
inside odorless and colorless tasting
tubes are helium and argon
this course would be a lot of fun with
each sip of helium gas you'd find your
voice sounding strange and high pitched
this would be amusing for a bit but
you'd start to feel light-headed i
really shouldn't be doing this that's
because all this helium would be
displacing the oxygen that your brain
needs
when your waiter arrived with the next
dish they would introduce it with a
peculiar warning
antimony could make you need to use the
restroom
yeah this semi-metal was used as a
laxative in medieval times
after your quick bathroom break it's
time for the smelly course
are you ready to be grossed out by the
smells of sulfur selenium and liver
morium
well you'd be surprised to find out that
these elements alone don't smell like
anything
sulfur and selenium only smell like
rotten eggs or garlic when combined with
hydrogen
and scientists haven't yet produced the
livermorium hydrogen compound
so we don't know what it smells like
but it's a highly unstable and
radioactive element so eat it quick
your waiter would now warn you that the
rest of the dishes
are not safe for consumption
but you're feeling a little risky so
you go for it anyway
to start your deadly dose of dishes
you'd have mercury
you wouldn't notice any immediate
effects because symptoms of mercury
poisoning like tremors poor memory and
difficulty walking
take a long time to develop
next two tiny portions of radium and the
noble gas radon
these elements are radioactive and
prolonged exposure could result in lung
or bone cancer
good thing your portions are small
because you could also experience nausea
and increased heart rate from acute
radiation sickness
okay finally you've reached the last
course of the evening
and the last course of your entire life
you'd try a little of the tasteless and
odorless arsenic
this would immediately cause nausea
bleeding and diarrhea
it could also lead to a painful death in
only a few hours
and you'd also get a taste of reactive
elements like francium and fluorine
these are dangerous
francium would react with the water on
your tongue and explode in your mouth
literally
and fluorine is so corrosive and
flammable
that it would burn nearly everything it
comes into contact with
especially you
so
that's where your tasting menu ends
sadly you didn't get all the elements
some of them wouldn't be able to exist
in a kitchen anyway
you'd need to visit a lab in order to
experience some of the most unstable
ones
now while some of the elements could
kill you after one bite there are many
elements that you wouldn't be able to
live without
like carbon
now what if we took away all the carbon
for only five seconds
well i'll leave that story
for another what if